dans le monde du travail
la journée continue est en passe de
devenir un événement social
elle a ses adeptes et ses adversaires
suivants le contexte dans lequel on
veulent introduire si non l'imposer dans
le pré vous avez des diplômes ça fait
froid industriel et bien j'ai des
enfants disponibles à l'heure actuelle
nous pourrons faire un essai dès demain
ciblée du tribunal
nous commençons à 8 heures et il termine
en 16h45 manager est une fusion
largement vie continue nous prenons nos
repas sur place au restaurant
d'entreprise avec un arrêt de trois
quarts d'heure je pense qu'une formule
conviendra que je vais y adapter il ya
j'espère nous et j'espère montrer ses
seins concluante ouvert et fermé
des essais sont tentés ici et là dans le
monde industriel ou commercial et
monsieur boinot qui dirige à niort usine
de confection et renard fait
l'expérience de la journée continue
sur quels critères se basent
industrielle que vous êtes pour
préconiser cette formule de travail avec
les terres bien sûr il fallait parler
d'implantation et il nous fallait
attendre une nouvelle implantation qui
nous permettait de prendre cette
décision qui correspond à une évolution
absolument réversibles
en fait nous en voyons beaucoup de
femmes et pour nous le premier critère
était d'épargné le nerveux
l'ailer nos employés par un trajet qu'il
était de plus en plus impossible et
aussi par des travaux ménagers de plus
en plus harassant
un problème se posait à ce jeune couple
travaillant dans des villes différentes
avec des horaires différents
traditionnel pour les pouilles journée
continue pour les poudres
là encore il fallait trouver une
solution et l'industriel emplir les
pousse à cordes à la faculté aux jeunes
couples de prendre son repas de midi
ensemble à son restaurant d'entreprise
concilier de social et l'humain c'est
aussi l'un des soucis des promoteurs
régionaux de la journée continue
lee
des rendez vous de la journée continue
eh bien d'abord la suppression des temps
morts tant dans la bouche de la débauche
il faut monter la peu près de 10 à 15
minutes de gains il faut compter aussi
un rendement meilleur pour les
collaborateurs comme il ne quitte pas
l'entreprise
il continue à penser à l'entreprise et
nous évitons là aussi une casse il enfin
bien sûr la diminution de certains frais
généraux en particulier je pense à nos
brasseurs passage qu'une étude obligé de
relancer point du vapeur à deux heures
et qui nous entraînait une perte de
temps une meilleure répartition des
heures supplémentaires qui a mis 14 ans
maintenant nous dans à la semaine
anglais c'est-à-dire le week-end complet
là aussi une fois généraux niang alors
comment se traduit dans les faits cette
évolution et quelles en sont les
conséquences le plan social bien sur le
plan individuel n'a surement bloc
ensemble ces heures de liberté
nous arrivons à donner un nombre
d'heures nécessaires à la vie familiale
à l'éducation des enfants à la culture
personnelle et aussi à l'ensemble de
certaines pratiques de sport etc
la belle saison surtout d'ailleurs et
l'organisation d'un site et autour de
cette idée qui permettra de voir de
meilleurs résultats
mais dès maintenant il est certain que
deux heures des libertés qui remplaçait
deux heures d' esclavage au moment du
déjeuner pourront permettre à la mère de
famille d'avoir de meilleurs
préoccupations que celles qu'elle avait
au brun
et ce repas aux migrants
les oiseaux la jolie continue la
transformer votre opinion oui le soir ce
soir à peine gêné mais en bon d'étendre
mieux qu'avant et comment vivez vous le
redire combien ce soir je regarde pas la
télé congo font rares
trois morts étaient des liens
intéressants l'église et pas sur les
étudiants et aux lycéens ou jeunes
actifs
votre mari est parti de là j'en ai
utilisé sur des graines but c'est bien
mais pas dire ce coup là peut-être alors
si vous deviez la paire oui c'est vrai
ça bien c'est toujours pareil ça en fait
puisque voilà je dois entendre
si vous deviez revenir les citoyens non
non ça va comme ça
l'éditeur
alors comment analysez vous votre vie
vous travaillez vous occuper de vos sens
jusqu'à l'approché de la plus parce que
j'arrive à cette eau et le soir je vais
garder encore un plus mais beaucoup
moins longtemps puisque est ce que vous
préférez la journée continue dans ses
souvenirs quand je partage des contenus
parce qu'on a quand même wade ne
serait-ce que hamidi et vous pouvez de
soi où le groupe est de me battre et le
soir je me suis davantage
donc c'est un bien là pour moi camarades
c'est beaucoup mieux pour moi c'est
beaucoup plus de temps libre
puis l'après midi on mange ensemble vous
avez atteint le savoir alors monsieur
boiteux pensez vous que la journée
continue constitue une préfiguration de
la politique des loisirs oui déjà avec
l'automation avec la semaine anglaise
on avait déjà vu apparaître pour les
jeunes certaines possibilités de loisirs
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas au port il
est certain est que nous aurons de plus
en plus nous pourrons dégager plus en
plus des heures de liberté mais je crois
bien sûr qu'il faut aller vers une
certaine organisation de ces loisirs et
que ce n'est que la prochaine génération
qui elle pourra en profiter pleinement
mais pour l'instant quand même cela va
pouvoir permettre une meilleure vie
familiale pourra permettre quand même
une culture possible de la part de gens
qui n'en avaient pas le temps et cela
pourrait permettre justement dans
l'avenir d'arriver à cette grande idée
de participation
il est un fait que si les gens veulent
participer il faut s'y préparer
pour s'y préparer il faut leur donner le
temps et de loisir de pouvoir le faire
ce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas donc passé